let's go let's go we're gonna be late
fun fact the first time I almost died
was at the age of nine the murder weapon
a Jimmy Dean sausage in fairness to mr.
Dean this one morning I decided to
forego my normal 20 choose provides as
prescribed by the American Medical
Association to further complicate
matters in any real-life crisis
my family's default mode is mindless
panic it's interesting the things you
think about when life is ebbing from
your body
for instance linoleum what is it really
plastic and if so how is it different
from Formica and what about Count
Chocula how is he account did the title
come with land
[Music]
don't they say in the final moments your
life passes before your eyes all I saw
was my brother
licking jelly off the knife and putting
it back in the jar you have to that
jelly I've never been late to school
before I'm late all the time it's no big
deal
I get you to school on time every day
why are you late I have a lot of people
I'm gonna say hi to in the morning mom
would you write a note for me sure you
have the coolest excuse you almost died
did you see Jesus I saw Count Chocula
but feel free to mention my brush with
death in the note alright that's enough
talk about death and dying I came this
close to having my own room
[Music]